There's a new controversy with
White House press secretary
-and belligerent owl,
Sean Spicer. -(laughter)
-Boy... that is...
-(applause and cheering)
That... that forehead is taking
up a lot of face real estate!
-(laughter)
-That is so much...
Honestly, I think
he should just rent this out
as a double-decker tour bus,
like, right up there.
Look at that. Come on.
-Look at how much.
-(applause and cheering)
(laughing):
How much room.
-Look at how much room that is!
-Hop on, hop off.
-HARDWICK: Hop on...
-(laughter)
Spicer's been open with the
public about his passwords,
gum intake,
and opinion on Dippin' Dots,
which is not the ice cream
of the future, he said.
-(laughter and groaning)
-It's not.
Basically, everything
except factual information.
So now, he's giving
the American people more access
to his Venmo account.
Twitter quickly found his public
Venmo profile, @seanspicer,
and bombarded him
with payment requests
for things like "anxiety meds
because your boss is a lunatic."
-(laughter) -Or "meeting with
the gays to buy him new suits."
(laughter)
But if anyone deserves
this minor inconvenience,
it's the alternative
fact-spouting
forehead known as Sean Spicer.
Now, we would never,
ever tell you, our audience,
to do such a thing,
ever, so don't do this.
But if you requested money
from Mr. Spicer,
screen grab it
and send it to us.
Maybe we would feature it
on the show.
Now I'm not saying do that!
-In fact, I'm telling you
not to! -(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-I am strongly...
In...
In my deposition,
the record will show
-I told you, do not do that!
-(laughter)
So, comedians,
what would you ask Sean Spicer
to pay for on Venmo? Katie.
A plate, a knife and a fork for
how often he has to eat (bleep).
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Very good.
-(applause and cheering)
Very good. Josh.
50 bucks so he can drill a hole
in the wall
of a truck stop bathroom for
none of your (bleep) business.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Points. Points.
-Seth.
-Gum-removal surgery.
I'm worried about him.
He's gross.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, all right.
Points. Very good. -(laughter)